je me dis que les français qui nous
regardent s'il n'était pas convaincu
avant de nous regarder de la nécessité
de réduire le nombre de parlementaires
et de renforcer le parlement et
l'activité l'efficacité du parlement en
regardant les débats des derniers jours
je pense qu'ils sont plus que convaincu
et le président ferrand le rappelait
fort justement c'est une posture
politicienne
en réalité vous aviez benoît mais
françois fillon eux-mêmes qu'ils
soutenaient la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires et nous ce qu'on veut
faire c'est justement renforcer le
pouvoir du parlement et qu'il retrouve
sa place dans l'organisation dans
l'institution dans la constitution
pardon de la vème république
et pourtant ce n'est pas ce que disent
les députés de l'opposition et les
sénateurs également qu'ils le dénoncent
un affaiblissement du parlement avec
cette réforme constitutionnelle oui
ceux-là mêmes qui dans leur programme
dans les programmes des candidats qu'ils
soutenaient disait exactement inverse
donc le président ferrand quand il parle
de statut de tartufferie je pense que le
mot n'est pas trop fort
vous êtes nous sommes en train de
toucher à un texte essentiel un texte
fondamental c'est un engagement du
président de la république
alors oui ça peut troubler qu'on fasse
ce qu'on a dit mais c'est les français
je crois le voit depuis un an
la ligne directrice qu'on s'est fixés
mais quand vous voyez qu'il y à vous
l'avez rappelé près demi 400 amendements
évidemment ça pose question est ce qu'on
est efficace est-ce que hier une journée
d'obstruction parlementaire
vous savez combien ça coûte une journée
de parlement en france c'est 2 millions
et demi d'euros
pendant ce temps là on n'est pas en
train de s'occuper des vrais problèmes
qui sont que son kiki qui sont vraiment
l'intérêt des français c'est-à-dire
l'école la formation on est en train de
prendre du retard sur des éléments qui
sont essentielles vous appelez un
parlement fort mais dans le même temps
ce texte renforce la mainmise de
l'exécutif sur le parlement sur l'ordre
du jour sur le droit d'amendement
mais pas du tout vous avez trois
missions constitutionnelles pour le
parlement c'est faire la loi
contrôler l'exécutif et mesurer les
politiques publiques
aujourd'hui le parlement ne fait pas ça
il travaille beaucoup mais il ne
travaille pas bien et tout le sens de la
révision constitutionnelle de la loi
organique de la loi ordinaire et j'irai
plus loin de la réforme des règlements
en tout cas du règlement de l'assemblée
nationale et tout ce que
aussi du côté de la questure de
l'assemblée nationale toutes les
transformations que nous menons vont
dans le sens de d'un parlement plus
moderne plus exemplaire plus efficace
plus rationnelle en termes de dépenses
publiques est au fond un parlement plus
fort aujourd'hui il faut partir du
constat qui est le nôtre
est-ce que tout est ce que vous pensez
que le lien de confiance entre les
français et les parlementaires il est
bon aujourd'hui
est ce que quand on a un taux
d'abstention dernières élections il ya à
peine un an qui est de ce niveau quand
on a une radicalisation des positions
n'avaient l'extrême droite l'extrême
gauche anti européenne et une droite
radicalisée en phase finale d'une
élection présidentielle entre 20 et 25
points 20 le conseillant pas réduire le
nombre de parlementaires va accroître le
lien entre les français déjà c'est fait
ce qu'on a dit on l'a promis c'est un
des engagements du président de la
république et donc moi je crois vraiment
que les français sont attentifs au
respect de la parole publique c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on renouera la
confiance et l'idée c'est d'avoir moins
de parlementaires mais des
parlementaires plus fort et donc tout le
sens des réformes qu'on mène c'est
justement leur donner les moyens
d'exercer leurs missions
quand on parle d'évaluation des
politiques publiques on est en train de
mettre en place justement les outils
pour exercer ses missions aujourd'hui
ces missions ne sont pas exercées les
relations se sont tendues ces derniers
jours entre la droite sénatoriale gérard
larcher et le gouvernement est ce que
vous pensez qu'un accord est possible
encore entre le sénat et le gouvernement
sur ce sujet moi je pense que le
président larcher est un parlementaire
expérimenté il était élu en 85 de
mémoire donc il connaît bien
la maison senna je pense qu'il n'y a
aucun intérêt à revenir sur la parole
qui avaient été donnés lui aussi été
chef de file a soutenu
suivant les semaines monsieur fillon
mais en tout cas il a soutenu jusqu'au
bout la droite les républicains
donc je ne vois pas comment il pourrait
aujourd'hui se parjurait en quelque
sorte à ne pas trouver un accord donc
moi je pense que nous trouverons nous
trouverons un accord dans les prochaines
semaines